why do we matter  in this giant universe multiverse where  there's trillions and trillions of  galaxies and  you know even more  zeros on the end to how many inhabitable  planets there probably are why why do we  matter yeah that was one of my first big  questions when i  ended up getting abducted at the age of  18 and kind of blew the lid off of my  reality of oh my goodness  they do exist that they are here  uh why why us like why would they bother  with  human beings like this ant like species  you know in the universe this third  dimensional archaic caveman kind of you  know civilization once again it comes  back to this peace treaties for many  many like millions if not billions and  trillions and beyond years um there has  been an energetic battle happening in  the universe